paar Worte zu verlieren über die neue
Aufgabe
der Bundeskanzler hat mich gefragt ob
ich das Amt des
Bundesverteidigungsministers in seinem
Kabinett übernehme das habe ich dem habe
ich sehr dankend und sehr gerne
zugestimmt das mache ich sehr gerne das
ist mir eine wirklich außerordentlich
große Ehre dieses Amt zu übernehmen ich
weiß um die Bedeutung der Aufgabe gerade
in diesen Zeiten und ich danke meiner
Vorgängerin wenn ich das schon so sagen
darf Christine Lamprecht für ihre Arbeit
in diesen besonders schwierigen
herausfordernden Zeiten sie hat die
Neuaufstellung unserer Bundeswehr in der
Zeitenwende begonnen
mein besonderer Dank gilt natürlich vor
allem dem Bundeskanzler für das in mich
gesetzte Vertrauen
die Aufgaben die vor der Truppe liegen
sind gewaltig
ich werde deshalb meine Dienstgeschäfte
unmittelbar nach der Vereidigung am
Donnerstag aufnehmen um mich mit dem
Ministerium der Bundeswehr Führung und
natürlich auch den Parlamentarier und
den Parlamentariern austauschen
wie es bei all dem und das hat meine
Arbeit hier auch im Innenministerium in
Niedersachsen steht geprägt wichtig der
enge und vertrauensvolle Zusammenarbeit
mit den Menschen die mir in diesem Amt
anvertraut sein werden mit den
Soldatinnen und mit den Soldaten die
Bundeswehr muss sich auf eine neue
Situation einstellen die mit dem
russischen Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
entstanden ist mir ist wichtig die
Soldatinnen und Soldaten ganz eng in
diesem Prozess zu beteiligen und sie
mitzunehmen und die Truppe kann sich
darauf verlassen dass ich mich wann
immer es nötig ist vor sie stellen werde
ich will die Bundeswehr stark machen für
die Zeit die vor uns liegt
vielen Dank
vielen Dank dass Sie alle gekommen sind
das war das Statement von Boris
Pistorius es gibt keine Möglichkeit
Fragen also nicht zu meinem neuen Amt da
bitte ich um Verständnis
ich musste nicht lange überlegen dass es
ein eine so ehrenvolle
verantwortungsvolle Aufgabe der ich mich
niemals hätte entziehen wollen ich
glaube meine Erfahrung wird mir helfen
und der ein oder andere wird mich
möglicherweise aus diesem Haus begleiten
ja
das ist noch zu früh darüber zu sprechen
ja Demut und Respekt vor einer so
gewaltigen Aufgabe das
filmverteidigungsministerium ist schon
in zivilen in Friedenszeiten eine große
Herausforderung und den Zeiten in denen
man als Bundesrepublik Deutschland an
einem Krieg beteiligt ist indirekt noch
einmal besonders und von da bin ich mir
der Verantwortung der großen Bedeutung
dieser Aufgabe natürlich sehr bewusst
und bin umso dankbarer dass sie mir
zugetraut wird und werde mich vom ersten
Tag an mit 150% in dieser Aufgabe rein
stürzen
den wünschen sie sich als Nachfolgerin
oder Nachfolger hier das steht mir
überhaupt nicht zu der Ministerpräsident
wird das in Kürze bekanntgeben davon
gehe ich jedenfalls aus und ich bin
sicher dass er wie in der Vergangenheit
auch hervorragende Personalentscheidung
treffen wird
gestern
ich bitte ich bitte wirklich um ich habe
vieles im Kopf das können Sie mir
glauben ich lese seit gestern nichts
anderes mehr und auch in der
Vergangenheit hat mich das Thema stets
interessiert sie wissen dass ich an den
Bundeswehr Fragen immer sehr dicht dran
war aber ich werde heute zu dem neuen
Amt dass ich übermorgen erst antrete
inhaltlich noch gar nicht sagen dass der
kommt zu gegebener Zeit
sehr überraschend
an der Stelle möchte ich Sie gerne um
Verständnis bitten keine Fragen mehr
eine Frage noch
nein als Innenminister bin ich zwar am
verantwortlich und zuständig für die
Beziehung zur Bundeswehr nicht nur im
Katastrophenschutz auch darüber hinaus
ich habe mich stark gemacht für einen
heimatschutzregiment hier in
Niedersachsen war regelmäßig auf den
Bundeswehrstandorten auch auf den
marinestandorten habe die Fregatte
Niedersachsen als sie noch gab
regelmäßig besucht war bei Fahnen bei
Gelöbnissen bei fahrenheiten dabei
warenverleihung dabei also von daher
weiß ich um das was in der Bundeswehr
Thema ist und deswegen war es jetzt für
mich thematisch nicht so fern liegt
vielen Dank